on the surface it looks as if time has
Stood Still in Lisbon but behind the
Portuguese capital's quaint facades
there's a quiet revolution underway
Lisbon's become a major hub for startups
among them Gonzalo Fortas is pod smart
prod smart software ensures production
line transparency ideal for industry
4.04 des has a subsidiary in germany but
its headquarters stays in portugal
portuguese this is our home we've got
loads of talent here and the wage levels
are also favourable that helps when
deciding on location we've got our base
here but obviously we're on location
with our customers as well science for
you contracted pod smart provide the
software for its Lisbon factory signs
for you began business just as the
crisis hit in 2008
it makes experimental kits for kids and
it's expanding rapidly in part due to EU
regional economic programs the company
is very new very dynamic very flexible
one thing that helped us grow was state
aid which also came from the European
Union to help create jobs science for
you employs 120 people and is still
growing a fundamental Portuguese
priority nowadays is ensuring that more
people find work and because the economy
is growing again the country's
family-owned businesses support the
government in that to get the message
across their associations president says
it in English we've done fantastic we've
had an enormous success in reducing the
public deficit rather than getting a
sanction I think we should get a reward
but Brussels is threatening to impose
penalties because the recently elected
socialist government has called a halt
to spending cuts and some analysts are
also questioning if Portugal is a
worthwhile investment now the minimum
wage has been raised from 5
five euros to 530 euros a month these
criticisms are insults although our
middle-income German worker would
certainly be interested to know why it
is that some banker can preach the
Portuguese that a monthly wage of 530
euros is bad for the economy 530 euros
that's a very low minimum wage last year
Portugal's budget deficit almost fell to
within the EU limit of 3% of GDP but
past legacies caught up with a country
in Lisbon had to rescue yet another Bank
this year the state savings bank also
needs a cash injection